the roof is wide open here at t-mobile
park opening game
of the three-game series with the texas
rangers they ride into town with a
record of 10 and 14. the mariners eight
and 19.
mark gavin is ahead of the count here's
his 02. breaking ball he gets him to
swing and come up empty
good start for the mariners
swing and a miss for strike three
back-to-back strikeouts from our
gravitas to begin the game
colby allard three years old tonight
marks just his 14th big league start
into left field for a base hit nice way
for j.p crawford to begin things been in
a little bit of a slump
and there's a lead off single right
there here's left fielder sam hagerty
here's the o2 past the dive of frasier
at third and into the corner crawford
steaming around second those stirrups
being waved in he's flying home
meanwhile hagerty into third and he is
safe for
scoring triple two batters in the
mariners take a one nothing lead
here is center fielder kyle lewis the
infield for the range is up close
kicks away and hagerty can just waltz
home
[Applause]
two out the mariners austin nola batting
one out and kyle lewis in scoring
position
this got fisted a little bit dropping in
for a base hit
kyle lewis coming around the throw home
not nearly in time
bobbled by the catcher trevino and in
its second base goes austin nola
and the mariners now lead the rangers
three to nothing
so the mariners have two outs here in
the bottom of the first inning and
that'll bring up right fielder braden
bishop
bishop stings this into right field and
it is a fair ball and it hops over the
fence for a double
rbi double for braden bishop and the
mariners
tack on another run first base knock in
2020 for the former husky it's four
nothing mariners
gallop a poster child entering tonight
as to why batting average doesn't always
tell the full stories
cut on and missed there goes the helmet
throw that pitch again
third strikeout three the first four
batters faced
by margavitches go down on strikes so
one down
and here is catcher jose trevino
strike recall lower outside corner
one out that brings up kyle lewis lewis
stings this
rides it deep out to center field and
gone
home run kyle lewis
[Applause]
another one to dead center it's number
six on the
season
[Applause]
you can just stamp that rookie of the
year award send it right here to
t-mobile park
and there you go set up away i'll be
middle away 84 that's not speed pitch
102 on the x of a loss able to hit it
over 400 feet
[Applause]
second third left and right nick with
the one two pitch swung on and miss
struck him out
slider and that's eight up eight down
for
margavitches straight up in the infield
and outfield for solace who struck out
on a
0-2 pitch here's the next pitch in there
for it called strike three slider
outside corner
the runner in scoring position mariner's
five nothing bottom of the third one
pitch to d gordon but a beauty
third base side they'll never get him no
chance
benjamin ate it base hit d gordon lopes
the third runner's at the corners for
the mariners nobody out here in the
third
beautiful there's a 1-2 pitch here to
braden bishop hunters at the corners the
pitch swung on dribbler
towards the shortstop frazier cuts it
off throws over to first in time scoring
on the play as lopes
over to second safely is d gordon and
the mariners lead goes to six
nothing so first and second two outs for
heinemann
02 to heinemann and he shoots this one
over first that's a base hit
and we'll go for extra bases trevino's
in ref snyder
being away frantically around third here
comes the throw to the plate
not in time russ snyder scores from
first
and all the way to third base heinemann
it's a 6-2 ball game
kenny santana batting right against the
lefty mark
and the pitch is lying deep to right
field this is well hit
way back and that one is history an
opposite field home run for
danny santana his first of the year
and seattle's lead has been cut to 6-3
boy nice to see that danny a 30-30 man a
year ago
connects for the first time this season
the rangers keep their home run streak
alive they've homeworked now in eight
consecutive games
third one out in the top of the sixth
inning and the new pitcher is
right-handed joey gerber
roogie has flat out to right and flight
out to center gallow at third base
trevino at first base
2-0 pitch odor pops this one up
medium deep center field lewis with a
baseball
joey tags he'll score easily and it's a
6-4 ball
game so the rangers chipping away in
this one
still alive at third up the middle
odor with the backhand and santana
bobbles it
kyle lewis scores
it's a three-run lead for the mariners
right-hander taylor williams
a save situation will take over the
payoff
good on it missed two outs now the last
hurdle
isaiah connor falefa to seeger
he's got it strong throw mariners win
tonight
mike they take the first three against
the rangers